-How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
And we have had just
the most wonderful afternoon.
You, Fred, and I sat down,
and we got to catch up and talk.
And my second year at "SNL"
was your first year.
-Yes.
-And we, one day,
made a decision that we were
gonna go -- It was your idea.
-Yeah.
-You wanted to go to Boston
to watch Michael Jordan's
last game.
-Yes.
-In Boston.
As a Washington Wizard.
-Yes.
-Not his last game
as a Chicago Bull.
You wanted to see his last game
as a Washington Wizard.
-Well, I never got to a chance
to see him as a Bull,
so I thought this would be
my only chance
to see him play basketball.
-We had to get on a super-early
train to go to Boston.
-Yes.
-Because it was a day game.
And it was after "SNL."
-Yes.
-But that's really not
the crazy part.
The crazy part is what you wore.
Because this was a sketch,
the last sketch of the night
at "SNL" with Bernie Mac.
-Yeah.
-And this, I think, was Bernie
Mac's House of Comedy Suits?
-Yes, and I believe it was you
who talked me into wearing that
to the after party.
-Yes.
-So I was like,
"Ah, okay, yeah, I'll do it."
And wait. Did you not dress up?
-No, I didn't.
-Oh. Okay. I did-- Okay.
So, yes, I wore that
to the after party,
and then a couple drinks in,
I think you suggested,
"You should just go ahead
and wear that to the game.
Just wear it all the way up
in the train up there
and then wear it to the game."
And I was like,
"That sounds like a great idea."
-Yeah.
-And so I go on this train ride,
and a couple hours
into the train ride,
sobering up a little bit.
I'm like, "What have I done?
What have I done?"
I'm walking around --
"Oh, my God."
-And I should --
The best thing about this
was it was your first year
on the show.
You were definitely not famous.
-Oh, for sure.
-You were just
a super-weird guy in this suit.
Even though you had been
on "SNL" in that very suit
last night, nobody was making
the connection.
-I pull it off, though.
-Also, I don't know
if you remember that --
My parents met us at the game.
-Oh, yeah.
-That is when you met
my parents.
That was what you were wearing
the first time
you met my parents.
-And they still like me?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-I will say,
that is not even close
to one of the craziest things
you've done.
And you also have friends
who are very much in line,
I feel, with your fun of pranks,
enjoying taking chances.
-Yeah, I've got some
weirdo friends.
-And you have a friend
who gives a prank gift
to all of his friends
every year.
-Yes. There's this one guy.
He, for reasons you will see
soon, will remain nameless.
But one year, he gave us
a calendar of his poos.
-Okay.
-Which is gross.
And I still have it.
One year, he gave us a black mug
that when you heat it up,
images of his testicles
appear all over the mug.
-Got it.
-And then this year
for Christmas,
we're all sitting around.
John Solomon also received
one of these pillows.
This is what we got.
We get this, you know, simple --
Oh, geez.
You can kind of see it already,
but there is --
Okay, there we go.
So, this is what we got.
Just, like, a simple pillow
with metal -- silver sequins
as you can see.
Well, this is one
of those things where
when you rub it the other way,
an image comes out.
Let me show you
what's the image.
-[ Laughs ] Go over there.
[ Audience gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, let me --
That's the right side up.
[ Audience groans ]
-Now, obviously, put it down
because we're gonna
have to blur it.
And basically, people at home,
the only way
they're going to have to judge
what it was
is by the noise that they made,
the audience here made.
-It is a super close-up picture
of this guys ball sac.
-Yeah.
-And to give you an idea of --
It's so close-up that
just picture Seth's face
as a nut sac.
[ Laughter ]
It is like you're
looking at his nuts.
Like that.
-It's that close.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, what did you do with it?
-Oh, so, I received this thing,
and I'm like,
"This is great," but then I had
a really interesting idea.
I re-gifted it.
I brought it up to my mom.
Hello, Mom.
-Patty. Patty Forte.
-Patty Forte.
And I gave it to her with the
silver-sequins side up there,
and I'm like, "Mom, I thought --
Somebody gave me this pillow,
but it doesn't match
the color scheme of my house,
so I thought
it would fit in here."
And she was like,
"Oh, I love it!"
Like, I don't think
she really --
-Well, she looks like
she likes it there.
There's a shot of her.
-Yeah.
-Now, did you maybe goad her
into taking this photo?
-No. She does --
She is the best mom of all time.
So she loves anything,
even this like, kind of,
normal sequined pillow.
So she found a place for it.
-And I will say,
it fits right in there.
-It fits right in.
-But, now, has she not --
She's never found --
-It's been two months,
and my thing was like,
"I'm just going to see how long
it takes her to figure out --
to brush the thing
the other way."
And it's been two months,
and she --
This is the reveal to Mom.
[ Laughter ]
Merry Christmas, Mom.
I love you.
-We love you, Patty.
We love you, Patty.